Film Courage: At the time you made FORBIDDEN
ZONE after all these years that you think
about the time that you put into it and making
it, did you consider the original release
a failure?
Richard Elfman, Filmmaker of The FORBIDDEN
ZONE and FORBIDDEN ZONE 2: Economically, yes.
I mean it bankrupted me and I lost my house.
But artistically I was glad I did it.
Film Courage: At the time that you did it
you felt this way?
Or later you felt…
Richard: Completely glad I did it.
Film Courage: Really okay, wow.
Richard: Yes.
Film Courage: And so you are able to talk
a little bit about what happened in terms
of how it bankrupted you?
Richard: Yes, I had no idea what I was doing.
I didn’t clear the music rights.
The animation cost…(although I had a very
talented animator) it cost like 20 times what
I thought it was going to cost.
And I was just starting in real estate and
part-time jobs as a bus boy and a cab driver
and I’m forking money in.
It was like some people go to film school.
I just made a film.
Film Courage: Have you always done things
this way, sort of seat-of-your-pants and you
just jump right in and that’s how you learn
the good and the bad?
Richard: Yes.
Film Courage: Did people try to stop you?
Richard: Just economic.
Only economic.
Film Courage: Yes, that’s scary.
Richard: I had to shoot it in starts and stops
as I’d get some money.
I had a little bit of help from friends and
some partners.
Mostly on my shoulders.
Film Courage: And then I’m assuming you
took out a second on your house in order to
fund the movie?
Richard: Yes.
Well more than that.
To finally get it released I had to sign away
all control.
So I only got control of the film fully back
a few years ago…a long story.
But I only got one hundred perfect of FORBIDDEN
ZONE a few years ago.
Film Courage: So…I’m sorry.
What was the time span?
15 years?
Richard: 40 years.
Film Courage: 40 years.
Oh sorry.
Richard: The film was done 40 years ago.
Film Courage: Wow!
Sorry 15 seems like 40 years to me.
Are you thinking about this film every day
for the last 40 years?
Richard: No, I don’t think about it at all.
I think about the next dinner, the next article.
Film Courage: What wine we’re pairing?
Richard: Yes.
My brother [Danny Elfman] is writing fantastic
music that I have going through my head.
Film Courage: I know you’ve said music is
very important to you.
Richard: Yes.
I’m blessed with a very rich family life.
Film Courage: Sure.
I’m just hoping to get little nuggets that
we can give to our audience, there are a lot
of people that watch out stuff that…I’m
not saying they haven’t been as blessed
but they want to know how somebody gets to
this level.
And that is what we do with Film Courage.
Richard: Well a positive attitude is important
although I don’t know how you convey this
to somebody who has a negative attitude to
just tell them the words “Have a positive
attitude!”
You’re going to get knocked down.
You’ve got to get back up.
Everybody gets knocked down.
You’ve just got to get back up and go back
at it.
Film Courage: So you weren’t really thinking
about acquiring the rights back for all this
time?
Richard: No.
Someone acquired them, made me a partner,
it’s a long story and I only ended up with
it recently.
Film Courage: How would you say the theatrical
release of FORBIDDEN ZONE (the first one)
changed your life?
Richard: Well we were in the New Beverly Theater
now owned by Quentin Tarantino and there was
an arson threat and we had to leave.
No it didn’t change my life.
Well other than losing my house, that changed
my life.
But six months later I had a better house
with some real estate partners and things
worked out.
But again I had to pick myself up and go at
it again.
If I could give anyone advice it’s tenacity.
It’s if you’re tenacious your odds are
better.
The other thing I’ve learned is you get
periodic opportunities and we don’t always
take advantage of them.
I had a chip on my shoulder with Hollywood
for a long time.
And I was courted by agents and basically
here’s my card, knock on no door, I don’t
need stars, I’ll do it my way whatever.
But it was like I can’t even tell you a
few of the names that reached out to me.
But now I have a mellower view with forces
in the industry.
Then when I had my media company Buzzine I
got to see a little bit how things work and
how the wheels turn so it kind of took the
chip off of my shoulder.
Film Courage: Are you able to share how you
see things work?
Richard: Be aware that opportunities come
up and go for it even if you’re going to
fail.
But go for opportunities when they come up,
every one of them.
Your biggest regret I’ve read from people
at the end of their lives was not attempting
to do something.
I don’t know how many times Walt Disney
went bankrupt.
Film Courage: It’s a common thing we hear.
I know an actor gets to a point where they
say “I don’t want to work for free anymore.
I want to be treated as a professional.”
And that makes sense.
I would imagine that’s the same for directing
theater or film?
Richard: Well I just directed some theater.
When you direct small theater (even if you
fill the seats, you’re still going to loose
money.
Although the interesting thing is my wife
Anastasia is in a theater company (Force of
Nature Productions) and they put on one of
my plays last year.
And in the play I wrote that there was this
quirky band.
So for the play we actually put a band together
for the play and now the band is existing
on its own and they’re in my new film (Mambo
de Monaco).
Film Courage: I think I saw (a video) of them
playing and you were playing drums with them?
Richard: Yes.
But I didn’t make any money from the theater
production.
We filled our 90 seats (whatever).
But you don’t make money from small theater.
It’s for the love of it.
Well you do art for the love of it and if
make money then that’s a blessing as well.
But you’re not doing it for art.
And then if you make money, then that’s
a blessing as well.
But you’re doing it for art and that should
be its own satisfaction.